okay
um as always our recordings of our
virtual meetups will be available
on youtube about a week after the meetup
and we will post a message on the meetup
group when the recording is ready
so now i'm very excited and pleased to
introduce
sandra
dr sandra guessing
okay
okay she is a senior research scientist
at the discovery partner institute dpi
at the university of illinois system
her research focuses on science gateways
computational workflows as well as
distributed and parallel computing which
inherently leads to highly
interdisciplinary projects
she is
she is especially interested in
sustainability of research software
usability of computational methods and
reproducibility of research results and
she can support open science initiatives
i she is an academic editor of prj
computer science and frontiers
sustainability of research software has
many facets and she is an advocate for
improving career paths for research
software engineers facilitators and for
incentivizing their work via means
beyond the traditional academic
rewarding system
community outreach and introducing
interdisciplinary events are crucial to
contribute to changing academic culture
prior to the position at dpi she was an
associate research professor in the
department of computer science in
engineering and computational scientists
in the center of research computing at
the university of notre dame in indiana
u.s
before she moved to the u.s she was a
research associate in the data intensive
research group
at the university of edinburgh in the uk
in the area of data intensive workflows
and in the applied bioinformatics group
at the university of tubingen
in germany in the area of science
gateways and grid computing
additionally she has a perennial
experience as a project manager and
system developer in industry in the us
and germany
as head of a system programmer group she
has led long-term software projects like
infrastructure on web-based applications
she received her german diploma
equivalent to a master's degree in
computer science from extramural studies
at fan universe
hagen and her phd in computer science
from the university of tuber in germany
okay so i'm going to stop sharing
thank you so much
for this nice introduction
great
and
thank you so much for for the fantastic
pronunciation of fairness
okay
okay so you can take it over
sandra
yes
so let me share my screen you should see
my slides now
and i will start the slideshow
you have to be kidding me go away
why is it doing this now
come on
um
so
now it's okay
you see
okay so yeah welcome to my target
worldwide movement to improve the
recognition of research software
it's my pleasure to talk to this group
and i'm very excited that i've been
invited
so if we look at research software and
there were several
different surveys already in the last
years and this is one
where
where it was mostly answered in the uk
and in the u.s and researchers were
asked whether you know
whether they can
um do their research without research
software or with and uh how many of them
use research software and in the uk
ninety percent answered
that they use research software and
seventy percent that they can not do it
without and we have similar numbers also
in the us ninety-five percent youth and
63 that they cannot do their research
without any research software but
the whole
landscape does not reflect that in
training for example the
software engineers or the phds or the
students the postdocs who create
research software have neither formal
nor informal training 50
of them in software engineering and in
the us there's also a lack of career
paths still and also lack of an
incentive to stay in academia
and are in national labs
if you don't want to do the
normal
academic traditional career paths
so and if we look in the u.s so the
national science foundation for example
between 95 and 2006
had around 18
592 awards
and 9.6 billion
where they gave funding to
to
project that
reference software in the abstract so as
you can see the all the difference or
cses for example around computer science
around we have around bio around you
know education and also the different
areas so it's really
going all over the different domains
so so what is on a research software
engineer what do they understand under
you know this profession
and um
this is these are two definitions one is
from the u.s research software engineer
association i will talk more about
um
the
the ussr
and the other one is from the uk from
the society for research software
engineering
and we like both
um
at the u.s research software engineer so
it's really about around the the people
who
use the expertise for programming to
advance research to understand also also
researchers who who are interested to
create software or who are leading teams
work
which are creating software
so it's really a
big
yeah part of the research landscape
the research software engineer
so if we look at the
usrc the
u.s research software engineer
association so where does it cap
our term comes from so 2012 the software
sustainability institute
in the uk had a collaborations workshop
and
coined the the term research software
engineer
and then also the uk research software
engineer association formed in in late
2013
and since 2019 it's the society of
research software engineering and why do
i have these grassroots and
this
you know error here it's it's like
so the associations are really
grassroots um community organizations
that really people are very active
there and um from their communities and
working groups and you see a picture
here from one of the conferences in the
uk
and the other with the software
sustainability institute in the uk there
was also kind of leading
effort that that was planned so that it
was given top down to the community and
that there was funding so both made it
really possible to be very successful in
the uk
and the other countries really also
started to
to build this um
associations and as you can see it goes
really from africa to australia new
zealand
couple of countries in
in europe to and the uk and canada the
us which is very impressive and
you can see how much really this concept
also is needed for academia worldwide
this is by the way a nice picture from
from one of the conferences in germany
where
these are all people building the rcs
and it was an
yeah photograph from a tower
so and if we look at usrc
this is a map worldwide so these are all
our
yeah members
and usrc yes of course is mostly focused
on the us but that doesn't mean
membership is for free and if you are
interested also internationally you can
join of course uh usrt
there are webinars and things like that
uh
of course in the u.s time zone but you
can see people are interested to join
also
for our program
so how did the usrc form so it was
really a start in
2017 and 18
there was this u.s survey whether you
know rc's are needed what what kind of
career paths are there and
so
12 responded with interest to build the
national community
and then at the uk standard and
international rc leaders meeting there
were five us delegates i was one of
those
and so we created one in 2018 the slack
workspace and the first
website did go live and we did build the
steering committee
and this is the current steering
committee we we have
nine people
with different roles um
and we had
have already elections since 2020 so we
have two former steering committee
members
charles and jordan
who were also in on the
on the forming at
our steering committee when we started
off in 2018.
so what is the mission of usrc so one is
really to build the community to create
a professional community and to have all
these connections and knowledge and
resources
and also
not only to as a community but to
advocate and promote as ease
and the impact they have and the
importance of their res of their work
and then
resources so that there's access to
information and material
and we of course want to promote
encourage and improve diversity
throughout the broader u.s research
software engineer community
so how do we achieve that
so
so we built and really since 2018 a
couple of different um yeah program
topics
chances to interact with the community
one is a newsletter this is your the
communication
from from the com yeah from a group
working group to
to the community we have community calls
every month
we have working groups
and regional groups for example um so i
will go for all these topics a little
bit more into detail and so i'm at the
moment in forming a chicago regional
group so this would be very exciting
maybe if you are interested in joining
us we have a job board that which was
really also taking up
quite
quite fast and really well and
in average we have often like
20 jobs at the same time on the job
board for these we have virtual workshop
and we
shift to a conference next year so we
want to have a face-to-face confirm
which is planned for october 2023
in chicago by the way at the university
of illinois chicago on campus
so just you know
if you are interested i will i can give
also more information there
so we participate in conferences and
buffs and have a booze and
we start to have swag and
raffles for for swag
so that you know people can share and
advertise that this community is
existing
and we have an international committee
and international rc day so they as each
day will come up in october
and that is the idea since you have seen
this worldwide the community
that it's a chance maybe to exchange
some talks that
all of these internationalized e-days of
course through all the time zones
is a chance that that people can join
each other's
um
yeah presentations or whatever the
format is but
that it's really from from the different
continents together
and um usrc has built out now a couple
of partnerships for example with other
community organizations like the
academic data science
alliance and the community of
communities so the data science alliance
so we will have also went there and
they'll go into detail with that
so if you look at the growth
and that is just from the us and i'm
sure
also the the other
associations have seen much growth in
the last years
there's a recognition that this is an
important community and that research
software engineers are really needed in
academia and at national labs
and
these grows often
it jumps up a little bit when there were
events or
we participated in conferences but
i'm very happy with seeing that we have
over 1200 members
really since 2018 in four years so that
is
i think a fantastic
gain of members of course we want
more and to influence the academic
landscape
so if we go through the different topics
for example
so we aim at the monthly newsletter
um i'm responsible for it and i have to
admit
sometimes it's still only a bi-monthly
one it depends on how how the deadlines
are so the july one was published on
august 2nd and you see the different
topics so we have a couple of topics
which repeat in each newsletter and then
we we have for example
the steering committee recap is
one of the sections where where we
um inform everyone what
what the meetings were about um
we have the usrc virtual workshop coming
up in september
steering committee elections will be in
december again so we have every year
elections for the steering committee now
and so steering committee members are
then
elected for two years
and then
that place is
up for
election again
so
we we had the usrc activities at
parkview so you you see that there's
like their community news we have also
us e stories podcasts we have you know a
community forum and
and different working groups
so and our financials are at the moment
it's really a volunteer grassroot
organization at the moment which is also
very exciting but also it's hard without
having really
some funding so we are working on
funding also
with sloan and nsf and
otherwise we we are working together
with the open collective
as as a academic organization
and that we can represent the interest
of research software engineers in the us
so that it's financially not bound to
one university but really as an
organization
so yeah and if you are interested we
have the monthly community calls and
this is also very community driven we
have two people who who are
taking care of the organization around
it but so you can suggest topics you can
ask whether you can do
a community call uh bring your topic in
or organize one
or you know you can give a talk
so we are very open to different formats
here and
and people can can then organize with us
these community cards
so if you look at the different working
groups which have been really now
successful so the first working group
which was built was the di the diversity
equity and inclusion
working group and um
we had last year our first uh
speaker in the speaker series so we have
this about different topics of dei
and we have a media club so it started
as a book club and then it was a kind of
nice maybe also to include
podcasts or you know that's a different
media to discuss
and the i took also care of we we are
uploading that now to
yeah code of conduct
so
it's all around that you know
it's a really friendly welcoming
community
but you want to also make sure that it
stays that way
so yeah another working group is there
for the website
and that we have the new website now
the new layout i think for half a year
we have an education and training
working groups which are really looking
not only into
providing
for different topics but also
providing like lectures and webinars
we have an outreach working group that
looks on all different possibilities
from
supporting the newsletter to
looking at different conferences there
to be part of and
we have the group for working groups
which because everything was very um
nothing was defined of course and we are
still finding our ways what is working
well
with with communities or you know within
the community that people feel
encouraged to participate in a couple of
things but also really like what we
kind of programmed is there so the group
for working groups
defines at the moment
what working groups
how they can be built and then there is
the regional
regional groups working group that looks
into
because
you know so covert
is not going away but it starts that we
can have face-to-face meetings again and
it might be the nice to have this
regional groups
and that is also
when you look at this so this is these
are our members and there you see the
yellow dots
um that are regional groups at the
moment where someone felt responsible to
say oh i really want to do something
with the local community
and then set maybe meetings up
once and months or every two months and
do something that is of interest and
brings people together not only
virtually but also face to face in that
regard that you know because a lot of
research software engineers are still
working in silas and having
a local community uh can change that
so and if we look at the dropboard so
that is an example for the job where i
said yeah it's often really
filled so if if you have any
job position you may think that that is
really related to research software
engineers
are you know um maybe really affiliated
we have also related openings like
community managers in that space or
system engineer so so um
we have a couple of success stories
there that that really members did write
us oh
because of your job board i have now a
new position i'm really very happy so
glad to hear about you know success
stories from our job board
and if you are interested so the
registration
is open for for the usrc virtual
workshop
it is in september 14th and 16th
with the topic make it happen talk
towards a diverse and sustainable future
and
we will publish the program
next week so
just reach out to me or go to the
website if you are interested to do this
and
just saying it's coming up in two weeks
so but we have also other workshops so
for example another one which comes up
in in chicago
is the data scientist and rc career
support workshop
i thought if you are interested maybe to
be part of that so you can also
still apply for it and it's in october
and um this will be really with panels
about
what are the chances how can we improve
the career path for
not only research software engineers but
also for data scientists
and you see here we have a research
engineer software engineer um in hpc
workshop at supercomputing
and we will have a research software
engineer workshop at the escience
conference in salt lake city in in
october also so if any one of you is
interested i am happy to
to provide more information and
we had this year also a community
building workshop
funded by sloane that was in april
and we go to
a couple of other events where we had
buffs and talks like sci-pi so
you might have seen you know as as pie
dieter
group from our
our rse
event at sci-fi and we were at work
and why i'm talking about all this so
it's
to also show we are really
you know reaching out to the community
we are trying to invest the community
that that we have these grassroot
activities that
because there's so much potential in the
us
to have this momentum to change academic
culture in that regard
and so one of the things yeah you see a
very happy sandra in the one picture
that was our first flag
like
um
so with our logo on it so we
that so it's the first edition
that that we had last year and this is
um
yeah
and we had some further community
building workshops and he said okay we
still have some left so it would be nice
to have a raffle
and we brought out the rifle and we had
80 applicants
who wanted a top table or the backpack
and we used also
this opportunity to ask them whether
they can tell us what they really like
about usrc and whether we could cite
them
and a lot of them gave us a sentence or
and
and a lot of the people who said yeah
you can consider me with my first name
and you know the last name that i
first letter of the last name so the
best part of the usrc is the community
of active and friendly individuals who
are always willing to help their fellow
members uh follow members hello
um
so
and that is i i was very thrilled to see
that we had a lot of comments
about the community and that that we are
an open community
and i think we achieved that really also
for
focusing on dei from the beginning and
having really
a core team that is giving so much you
know on of their leisure time to build
this community and i'm sure nonfocus and
pi data also knows it
lives often with the forms who are
organizing things and the core
people who are getting active um so that
is really exciting
i also like that that people feel like
that it's really for countless research
fields that it's not focused on one
research field
and um
so
and the next citation is really about
that yeah
that we love to make it things better
for for the communities
and for education and to build
better and
do better so i really also like this
citation here from one of our members
so
if we look now
there's on the one hand side u.s
research software engineer association
but also in in the us we want to build
the research software sustainability
institute because this model was really
very successful in in the uk
to have the grassroot and to have
something with funding to be able to
organize
um more
around an institute where you can have
fellowships and
and different organizations so
i'm one of the copies of earthy
and so we have this different
we have these different areas to
conceptualize really
how should this u.s research of a
sustainability institute look like then
cut across the existing activities
funded by nsf and beyond and i mean
there's for example better scientific
software funded by doe
um
that that we are working together there
and not
trying you're not not reinventing the
wheel
so that we have direct or indirect
really positive impact
on software development and right
maintenance projects and that we focus
on the entire research software
ecosystem
um including
like you know the people the research
software engineers who create maintain
and use research software
and also not only the research software
engineers but also the user then
and
to really create our help to create
together with usrc to have this
supportive and inclusive community
so earthy was funded until last year the
conceptualization
and we had workshops we had a survey we
had ethnographic studies
we tried um a winter school
and yeah we have this area of
communication and outreach
and
so people so you can see here a picture
of one of the
workshops where we were brian
brainstorming really what what does the
community need besides the things that
are also happening
with other projects and and usrc
and what are all the challenges
and we came up then with
this kind of
yeah metrics that
that we really need
a development support for you know
consulting and you know short-term small
project support that that they can get
it from
off the ground and that we can show that
it has research impact and
it's therefore science the incubator is
then really technology advice business
planning usability advice
this will support again also software
and science and research
then we have seen yeah training training
is something really that is needed
in the field
and
um that people can
can go there for winter summer school or
in different formats where they can
split
for example online um
courses and that would support them
software people and all against science
we have the science always
with everything we looked at we think it
will be always
supportive for science
and we look you know
how can we create some policies around
research software and especially also
for
sorry for that
so
so that that there are campaigns for
especially for career paths
and that there is a wrong community
really fellowships blogs website
workshops that that works together with
usrt
and this was um what we have done we
have the five copies we worked with 16
senior personnel we had
nine
advisory committee members
and in
three years we had 47 public talks and
30 winter school students
selected from 169 applications we did
our survey
i will talk a little bit more about that
and
we we had five workshops
and from 90 different institutions with
150 workshop attendees and then
newsletters and 36 blog posts and three
ethnographic studies
and from
so the the survey is published so the
raw data is out there we wrote also a
paper
that got published at the beginning of
this year so you can
see the reference here i'm happy also to
forward it
so
we got really also interest from many
different disciplines if you look here
the mathematical and physical sciences
were
the most people who were involved
480
but you see that for example
also medicine we had
even seven from creative and performing
arts
yeah it's not
but
i i would say the diversity gave us a
good insight
we also really liked that there was a
social sciences in a high number
to understand
this part of
research also and we
asked them to define themselves are
there researchers
interested in research software engineer
nearing
our developers or both
because in in that field we have a lot
of as you can see the combination that
people say oh
i'm still a researcher in my domain but
i'm also
a kind of a research software engineer
so and if we look at the different
aspects here
um so we had
you will see
we had a lot of
questions for example about
training about available resources about
whether they can see a career path on
their site
um and so i picked some of the answers
we got
during the survey
and here you for example you can see
how people answered the combination of
developers and researchers and the
developers on what are really
aspects of software development that are
more difficult than they should be
because that's not the training or not
the right funding or
not the tools there and you can see that
it's a little bit different in the
combination that for example
communication
is something that
where the you know researchers who are
also developers said this is so hard
and
it shouldn't be that way why developers
thought it's not the hardest topic
they thought
really to get the person
this is what is really shouldn't be that
hard
then
which is really
you know shows one of the problems in
the ecosystem is
there is not sufficient time for
training if you see
um that really researchers say okay
there's almost no time if you
see here the
the dark ones are other no
um so that that is a real problem so
that means we we need a cultural change
in that regard that
that there should be time for this
then another
to how are people supported really
from their institutions
and
also here you can see that there is
really
a big lag on on the consulting on
financial side
where the infrastructure seems to be a
kind of okay
so
where people felt like oh yes it's
adequate
or
um
but it's then you know it's still
inadequate in the level of support even
so if for example if the infrastructure
is okay
so and it's really so career path is one
also of my
areas that i'm very
keen about and enthusiastic to improve
that for for the community and you can
see
that really career advancement for
software developers in academia
seems to be
really missing so there is a don't know
aspect but which also means
that that there is not a clarity at
institutions about it or maybe they
don't even
have a career path for for a research
software engineer and then
some developers have when they're
already working at an institution seems
to have a better
experiences
but the combination of both are really
looking at it like oh that there's not
many support there
opportunities
so if you're interested we rewrote
everything in an implementation plan
um what kind of support we would
like to give via the
earthy
and
so
the conceptualization ended last year
and we just
got a couple of grants
re-energized earthy again and uh so one
is an eager ground to look really deeper
into
you know characterizing research
software from nsf awards to to really
show what is needed there then we have
three grants
from
from the sloan foundation and then one
we are looking for a postdoc the other
one we are looking for a community
manager
so
if you are interested
there please reach out to us
so the outlook is really
that we hope that we can build this
software institute research staff and
sustainability institute in the us
that usrt is further growing that we are
working together with the centers of
excellence which which are often also
very related um
with software and infrastructure
and
so the sgx3 the science gateways
community institute just got the funding
to be continued for the next five years
so i'm a copier of that
and the community of community is one
looking into really all these different
um professions
which are not so
much supported at the moment yet it gets
better but it's still a lot of work
ahead of us so
it's not only research software
engineers but hpc facilitators
research computing professionals
research data professionals who are all
not
having or don't need to have this
traditional academic path and there's a
lot of momentum in in that area at the
moment
and
with that i would like to switch
to a many meter i hope you would like to
fill that out
for me to understand
oh sorry
so
you see the number here so if you go to
to mandy.com and put in this code and
maybe someone can also copy it
in the chat
or has done that already thank you so
much
so that would be
yeah my interest
so okay so three people already who know
now what
that there is an rc community
this is very good
i'm glad that
that one already didn't know about it
so glad
that we are doing this webinar
so yes so
i hope some new people joining it
so i'm not so sure by ah okay
are you yourself a research software
engineer from the definition
of maybe an ellie who says oh
i'm i'm not myself but i'm using
research software and i would be really
interested to improve this situation
for people there or you are not sure
whether this is something
so research software engineer so if i
see the numbers here
um
then i think it's it's great that you
know we talk uh that we talk about this
because only one person didn't know that
there is this community and
for
what self see as an aussie and the one
person who's not
sure but you're probably an ally because
you are interested
so
that is very cool
and not sure okay
so would you like to join a regional
group in chicago then for example was
that something
you could imagine would be interesting
to to just have
something like you know coming together
and discuss maybe
challenges
uh you know
not sure i understand because at the
moment it's still also building as long
as you don't know
what's really going on i'm totally with
you it's probably hard to say whether
you really would like to do it
but um yeah we are working on
developing a concept there
so
and this is like an open-ended question
if you want to put maybe
just a couple of terms and then what do
you think could ussrt do for you what
would be interesting for you could it be
training
could it be having a community could it
be
something yeah
like
um
giving you a platform for questions in a
slack channel
of
finding projects to contribute to
i like that also very much
more awareness of research software
engineers and training that makes
totally sense
have change incentive or yes absolutely
and provide a platform for exchange of
ideas absolutely i i think the incentive
that is one of the big topics for
improving
um the situation for research software
engineers
learning and education training yeah
so and letting industry practitioner
known when summer research software is
ready for wider adoption
that is a great idea also i like that um
because the collaboration with industry
is still also a very wide open field i
think
where a lot of things need to be done
thank you for all these answers
so what would be your ideas for your own
involvement would you be happy maybe
to organize
training with people you know together
um
would you
would it be enough for you to have a
community would it be something like oh
a community called or a working group on
something specific like python libraries
what would be of interest right
yeah i know it's a little bit tougher
to answer that
in one or two minutes
so
let me look at the chat that i missed
something
okay
oh i'm sorry
we are not in chicago okay
so
it would be also the wider area but um
so regional groups will also
be
in all over the us so that is a goal
so if you're not in chicago yeah we you
hope
that in your area will be also soon than
another regional group
so with this
i will
finish the manti meter
go back to
my presentation which just
it's at an end and i would like to
acknowledge in this wonderful ecosystem
my colleagues and collaborators from
from erc and usrc but also from the
science database community institute
there
a lot what went here into into the
slides and
thanks for your attention
so any questions
oh yeah ethan um oh yeah the 25
character i love it
um so python libraries i'm happy
to you know if you should join us at
it's for free
um there's a slack channel
and um
there is already
the python group started there
but it's very fresh and not
very active at the moment i think it's
very fresh so if you would like to do
something there that absolutely
um
are you open for questions
oh yeah
okay
so
at the beginning of the slide you showed
the nsf
as a funder and all the software it
funds
um
when i communicate with nsf officers at
the time it seems that they fund only
academic institutions
and part of the problem is that a lot of
the software research is actually not
done now by academic institutions yes
there is some contribution this and
there but basically there's kind of a
detachment in academia and actually the
people who now fuel the software that's
being
used in academia it's i see it all the
time
so uh
did you try to open the channel or
communicate with them to perhaps
give funds for things like this outside
academia
so we talked with nsf and this is also
now the eager grant what we want to look
at is
what kind of software
is used in academia
and which ones are funded by nsf
and to have the comparison and we hope
that this grant leads to collaborations
with industry and national labs and you
know national labs have also a lot of
creation of software so um
and i know that they cannot accept the
nsf funding it has to be do e or dod so
so i think
better scientific software for example
that group is funded by doe
and we have a close collaboration with
them so so we really try to bridge
there and
make the situation better
so i think if nsf realizes
that it would be good there could be we
hope that could be more collaboration
between
um
yeah the funding buddies then
if they need to stay you know i i'm not
totally sure why
why national labs are not allowed
are not allowed to to accept the nsf
funding or you know they cannot get it
but maybe some we hope that something at
least collaborative can can be done
between
those ecosystems
i wasn't talking about national labs i
was talking about like for example
a lot of the
python
libraries that are developed all over
not necessarily by academia all the time
industrial time just people on their own
time
yeah so it's like that is true yeah
sorry also industry this is what that
was meaning
basically the funding goes to fuel
academia but well well but the people
who are actually fueling academia now by
software are actually not getting paid
so and this is what that was meaning
yeah
yeah sorry for
so industry industry honestly i think um
that that would be also something good i
i know that nf
that's the
sbir um program that also industry and
startups
[Music]
um
yeah industry as consultants we can do
that
so that means um
if there are groups you know who ask for
academic money
from nsf they can also include
consultants for
for certain
um tasks so so maybe that is something
also to catch up on and say okay
this person did all these fantastic
python libraries which are used all over
the research domain
i i think the
that is also a little bit on the
academic cultural change we need that
people are thinking about that
um
and we have one
group in the slack channel who are
thinking about how to bring industry and
academia together
in the software space
so that might be something to suggest
also
with the next grant you know why not
including someone from
industry who are working already on
on these
python libraries on these javascript
values you know
whatever it is what would fit for
for it
i think when the researchers start to do
this
then
nsf won't have a problem with that they
changed for example in some of the
programs already that you have to have
like a one pager for research software
engineers to say oh
what is the institution doing for
supporting this role if if you have them
in your
budget so i could imagine if you say oh
yeah it's a research software engineer
but
they are from from industry because they
are the experts on in
that specific library we need
i think that that could work when
researchers start to do that
so yeah but yeah definitely a fantastic
awesome suggestion
so robbie i see a
comment for the slack channel
i can let me
send you the url where you can join and
then
i'm sorry
it's at the moment
a little bit slow i hope you still
hear me well
so let me
put that into the
[Music]
zoom so here is
how you can join us for free and i
promise
as i said i even have the problem more
that you know with the newsletter
that i'm not always monthly directly but
so we won't spam you you
can join there and um
and for those lectures you will see
they are quite lively and
you can see the different working groups
and everything
okay
thank you so much
i have another question it's like i was
i was waiting for someone to jump in
otherwise i'll be asking all the
questions all around um
you said
incentives what are the talks about what
incentives are possible that you
currently have ideas or things that you
heard because this is one of the things
that
i see problems like people who develop
great software having problems getting
funding they do all sorts of things i i
talk to them and i see what what's like
they
today whatever the people who are
actually doing things i have to do other
things just to
create this great software
so what incentives are you providing i
have some ideas of loan but i don't want
to you know
so with the incentive what we are
thinking about because
academia and also the national left
probably will never be able to
uh yeah be in competition really with
this industry with the salary it it just
that won't be
you know
we hope that it gets a bit better but
never been never google salaries in in
academia so so so we are aware of that
but we think that incentives are
first of all if people are really
interested in research
uh or to support research that they have
a good career path and not not have to
do something else as you said to just
support
um
the software they want to write so the
one idea is that they're really these
career paths where you say it
you don't have to write papers you don't
have to
you know bring in money
to
to contribute to be able to stay in
academia you can be really if you want
to that is okay but you know it's not
necessary for this career path so that
is something we are looking into that
that there is a recognition also
if researchers
you know needs of it that they put them
into into their grants to to have a
piece of you know
a research software engineer
and in their projects
so
so that we can offer something like a
really interesting
landscape where you can work for with
different researchers
that was one of the incentives we are
talking about but really also the
recognition that
that academia sees
research software engineers are really
important to
for research nowadays
and that this is reflected
in
being treated with a real you know with
a respect
being
integrated
into projects being
and not being treated and i don't mean
it mean that everyone probably knows
what i mean it's like not being treated
like a phd student
you know like oh
you just have to do it and um you know
you work i can send you an email at 10
p.m in the evening and it has to be done
tomorrow at 9 00 am no
they are not you know phd students
they are professionals
so it's you know um
so i i think and this mismatch
still
that
yeah that there is not a real profession
yet officially at all universities
that that is i think something we really
want to change to to make that situation
better
and that would be i i think an incentive
to say if you if you cannot you know
offer the money
you have to offer a fantastic welcoming
environment where people would like to
stay
and interesting work
yeah i got you
okay
well we're coming a little bit past
seven but
thank you so much for like a really
lively discussion and
for yeah leading us through that topic
sandra
um
we'll have another meeting um coming up
next month so keep an eye out for some
notifications
um usually always at the last thursday
um yeah but thank you so much
so thank you this was really a nice nice
discussion i enjoyed very much yeah it
was really cool i want to tell like my
lab who has like a software developer
because i don't think he knows about it
so i'm like yeah good needs to know
but uh yeah thanks so much
have a good night
you too thanks bye